aren't we sinning when we celebrate
Christmas because when we celebrate
Christmas on December 25 Jesus could
freeze
and he put his age on here he's nine
years old
no uh we we there there is a difference
of opinion concerning how valid December
25 could possibly be most Bible scholars
do not believe that Jesus was born on
December 25 what we do is commemorate
his birth and you can do that most
anytime you see and it is not wrong to
do it I think we ought to understand
however that there are pagan roots to
the Christmas celebration the other
night I mentioned that there is baptized
paganism
and if we understand what we're doing
it's not wrong to celebrate Christmas
but Santa Claus
and these round balls attached to a tree
which represent the planets which were
worshiped as Idols have nothing to do
with the birth of Christ neither does
the poinsettia
upon Santa we generally say
you see there was a time when they
believed that the son was a God and that
Nimrod when he died his Spirit emanated
from the Sun and they bowed down to
worship that and as the sun went across
the heavens they said Nimrod was riding
his chariot now every year at a certain
time of the year in the north and that
is in Europe especially where this came
from every year the days grow shorter
and shorter and shorter you know that
don't you and the pagans felt that the
sun might disappear forever because the
days were getting shorter and should
that happen everything would die
and so they began to offer their prayers
and by the way the evergreen tree was
the promise that the sun would return it
didn't die all the other trees lost
their leaves in their color and died and
so the evergreen tree became very
special and then around December 25
there's a leveling off and the days
don't get shorter instead they begin to
get a little longer and a little longer
and they used to worship and have a
festival it was called in some sections
a yule Festival that's where you get the
word Yuletide and Yule time and they
would have Lodge logs burning in the
Square a fire represented the Sun the
Poinsettia with its yellow sitter and
its red leaves represents fire the
candles usually are red representing the
sun all of these things were paganism
and when the Christians began to fall
away they reached out and took these
favorite Pagan festivals and United them
now when I have a celebration of
Christmas if I'll call it that we have
family reunion and on Christmas morning
we begin with worship Thanksgiving that
Jesus did God and that he was born and
babe in bethlehem's manger that's true
and he grew up to become Our Savior we
celebrate that also Christmas is a time
of Goodwill even old drunks and Crooks
and everybody seems to smile at
Christmas time I remember during World
War II they used to celebrate on the
battlefield they wouldn't even shoot at
one another if Christmas could do that
it can't be all bad what do you say so
it's not wrong to have a good time at
Christmas time just leave off the
paganism don't get caught up in that you
when my children were growing up as hard
as I had to work and as poor as I was no
little fat fellow with a long beard was
going to get credit for what I gave them
I wasn't going to tell them an untruth
either we better go Pastor Brooks please
explain First Corinthians 14 34 let your
women keep silence in the church for it
is not permitted unto them to speak
let's go right at the Romans and I think
it's 13th chapter and it says custom to
whom customers do honor to Humana this
is a cultural thing and in the Middle
East in those days oh by the way in
these days I was in a town called astute
in Egypt and they took me to church and
there was a rope right down the middle
with a canvas hanging and I said what is
this all about he said well over here
the women sit on one side to men on the
other now the custom was in those days
as it is today in some areas that women
had to be quiet in church and if they
had a question they'd just stand up and
yell to their husbands who were sitting
on the other side it created irreverence
Saint Paul wanted this corrected in the
Christian church he said let the women
keep silent this does not mean that a
lady
should not teach or a lady cannot speak
in church didn't mean that at all it was
a custom due to the cultural traditions
of those churches in the Middle East and
Paul said if you got any question ask
your husband when you get old but don't
stand up interrupting the church
irreverently by screaming questions
across the aisle that's all it meant
women outnumber men in the church if
they didn't speak up some Churches would
be in trouble
Pastor Brooks you said in the new Earth
it will be as God originally intended it
to be does that mean we will be truth we
will be fruitful multiply in the new
earth oh I don't know if we're going to
get through all of these may I give you
a personal I want you to understand this
is my personal idea
is that all right long as you understand
it I'll give it to you God created Adam
and Eve and said multiply and replenish
the Earth
the original comes closer to saying
multiply and fill up the Earth God had a
purpose now this Earth is only so big
and right now we have a population
explosion and we have anthropologists
telling us that by the year 2020 there
will be too many people on Earth for the
earth to sustain unless there is tragedy
wiping out multiplied thousands at a
time
when mercy told and showing live where
the head of China the statement came out
in the newspaper that for them war was
inevitable
they said we've got to fight a war if we
lose our ranks will be thinned if we win
we can spread out my Conquest
they had so many people in China they
needed rule therefore they felt they
must fight
now having said that I believe that God
had a number in mind when he told Adam
and Eve to multiply and fill up the
Earth
and if they had not sinned I think no
one would have died and he would have
reached that number and the Earth
couldn't hold anymore and I don't think
procreation would have been necessary
after that I have the feeling that God's
making up that number now and when the
saints all get to heaven he's got his
number and they will inherit the earth I
don't see any need for having babies in
the new Earth and the Bible doesn't
teach it and that's the answer you want
it next week sir if the body breath
makes a soul
where does the Holy Spirit or Holy Ghost
go after a person dies
I I don't quite understand this you ask
about the Holy Ghost the Holy Spirit
where does he go after a person dies he
goes to somebody who's alive trying to
win that soul to Christ the holy spirit
is not in essence the holy spirit is a
person
a person of the godhead who happens to
be omnipresent Omni present meaning he
could be everywhere to say die but he is
a person of the godhead and unless we
understand that we are missing one of
the great basics of scripture the holy
spirit is a person and his work is to
visit in places like this and to
convince men and the Bible says when he
has come he will guide you lead you into
all truth that's his work he is wooing
souls to Christ if a person dies there's
nothing else to be done he works amongst
the living next please Pastor Brooks in
Isaiah 65 25 it says the wolf and the
lamb shall feed together and the lion
shall eat straw like the bullet and dust
shall be the Serpent's meat doesn't that
say there will be serpents in the new
Earth yes please distinguish between
Heaven and the new Earth would you do
that when God brings the holy city down
to the Earth and recreates this world
his original plan will be resumed the
other night I was talking about heaven
said there'd be no serpents up there but
when we get down to earth there will be
lions bears tigers
serpents the new Earth not heaven next
place Pastor is it wrong to celebrate
your birthday
oh no my birthday is July 24th and I
want everybody to celebrate it with me
glad to be here Pastor what does the
Bible say about interracial marriage
the Bible doesn't say much about
interracial marriage I think there are
people who would like to make God a
party to racism he will not be in God's
sight all people are equal we are
brothers by creation Brothers by
Redemption
now all of these social problems have
come to be a creating problems for
people who want to marry interracially
it is not wrong they are precious and
before you get into it you ought to wear
it and know that you can deal with it
and if you can deal with it and you both
love the Lord there's nothing wrong with
it is that clear
now the Bible tells us that Moses
married an Ethiopian woman and Miriam
and Aaron got to arguing about it and
God cursed Miriam with leprosy
and only the prayers of Moses could
straighten her out
God didn't like it because Moses was
married to an Ethiopian woman
and Miriam complained and you can
believe she wasn't the only one but when
she turned leprous everybody got to
listen and backed off it is not wrong
sometimes it's not wise sometimes it's
not wise for a white to marry a white
you need God to lead you at that time
and if he leads you it's all right next
please Dr Brooks the Bible speaks of
Hell who's going to hell and who is
going to Purgatory please touch on this
subject well first of all we've told you
at night after night nobody's going to
Purgatory that's an invention of the
Roman Church there is no such place may
I repeat that there is no such place
when a man dies he goes into the grave
and he's going to stay there until one
of two resurrections the first
resurrection is the resurrection of the
righteous the second one is the
resurrection of the damn there is no
Purgatory now you want to know who's
going to hell the Bible says the wicked
shall be cast into hell but in Matthew
25 41 the Bible says Matthew 25 41 the
Bible says hell is prepared for the
devil and his angels hell wasn't
prepared for you now if you want to join
him you can enjoy it with him but it
wasn't prepared for you Christ is trying
to keep us out of there would somebody
say amen I don't want to go to hell I
want to go to heaven next week Pastor
what can you tell us about the history
of the Easter Bunny and Santa Claus oh
boy we almost got into that a while ago
in the spring of the year we went to the
uh the ceremony at Christmas time in the
spring of the year
after the dead of winter is passed
everything comes alive
I remember a poem that says in the
spring the young man's fancy lightly
turns the thoughts of Love or something
like that in the spring when the sap is
running
birds begin to meet and rabbits begin to
meet and all kinds of things happened in
the springtime nature reproduces in the
springtime now in Europe especially
amongst The Druids and others the pagans
worshiped many goddesses of spring
oh my we could go way back with this
even in Greece it was Aphrodite the
Goddess of love in Rome it was Venus the
goddess of love and Diana the moon
goddess that's why when you get married
you have a honey
it's supposed to affect love making and
reproduction now in those days if two
people got married in the springtime and
wanted to have children they worshiped
at The Shrine of one of these false
goddesses one will say I strike and it
was believed that the goddess of
reproduction would bless you and you'd
get pregnant at least the wife would
Now ladies and gentlemen in connection
with these ceremonies they had rabbits
that are very prolific they had chicks
that hatched in what is it nine days or
something or three weeks but anyway you
know the egg is a symbol of reproduction
and that's how it got into that Pagan
ceremony and when the church baptized
paganism and the people loved it so much
they said well let's keep it we will
co-join it with the resurrection of Our
Lord now I believe in the resurrection
of Our Lord thank God if he be not risen
our faith is being but an egg and a
chick and a rabbit had nothing to do
with our Salvation it's paganism next
please
if we choose not to come to church can
we be saved if we don't want to come to
church can we be saved all you need to
pray about this
I don't know why people want to join
Christ and not join his church he does
have a church and in Hebrews 10 25 you
ought to write that one down Hebrews 10
25 the Bible says for sake not the
assembling of yourselves together as a
matter of some is and so much the more
as you see the day approaching
we ought to go to church more
and those who go to church know that
they grow stronger when they do and we
go when they don't would you say amen
and the Bible says go to church by the
way the word church comes from Ecclesia
we get the word Ecclesiastes from that
Ecclesia and it means an assembly of
cold ones for deliberation and worship
Jesus said where two or three are
gathered together in my name there am I
so you don't come to church to hit
Pastor Brooks you don't come to hear
Pastor Ortiz as wonderfully as he sings
you've come to church to meet Jesus and
then to hear from him and to talk to him
next week he is a person that wants to
know what do you think about all these
gossiping women
really now
well I think it's awful
I really do I I don't think we ought to
get into uh gossiping and women doing
all that the Bible says in first Timothy
5 beginning with verse 12 having
damnation because they have cast off
their faith and wherewithal or with all
they learn to be idle wandering about
from house to house and not only Idol
but tadless also and Busy Bodies
speaking things which they ought not
the Bible doesn't like gossiping women
now
I want to talk to you about gossiping
men
some of the biggest gossips on the top
side of the Earth are men
psalm 15.
the Bible says Lord
who shall abide in thy Tabernacle and
who shall dwell in thy Holy Hill in
other words the psalmist is saying Lord
who's going to be saved and then he
answers he he is masculine
singular he man he that walketh
uprightly and worketh righteousness and
speak of the truth in his heart he that
backboneth not with his tongue
Lord doeth evil to his neighbor nor take
it up a reproach against his neighbor
who's going to heaven the man that
doesn't gossip
women do not have a corner on Gossip
this is the final one for tonight please
comment on Christians who do everything
we Sinners do oh you are laboring under
misapprehension Christians don't do
everything Sinners do
would somebody say Amen
the folks you're talking about are not
Christians they're called hypocrites
but Christians do what Jesus did they
obey as Jesus did they follow as Jesus
did would you say Amen
stop calling these Hypocrites Christians
just because they go to church
Christians don't do everything Sinners
do
how do you know when you know you're
really good enough to for baptism Pastor
the truth is when you repent of your
sins accept Christ as your savior love
him enough to obey him you are ready for
baptism
and that's all you need to know the rest
of it is Grace
Jesus supplies it next please
he is a person that wants to know where
was Daniel when his three friends were
being thrown into the fiery furnace
Daniel was prime minister in Babylon and
as such he had business and they didn't
have planes and helicopters then they
traveled long distances he was in
another Province next had he not been it
would have been the four Hebrew boys not
three
Pastor I've been baptized three times
and severely backslidden three times
should I be baptized again and here's
another question that's similar last
night you talked about baptism please
tell me what the Bible position is on
re-baptism and so forth thank you now I
don't know who writes these and if you
have severely backslidden I'm glad for
the grace of God that he'll take you
back
you know he goes beyond what humans will
do even what some parents will do he'll
take you back but you ought to come to
the place where you are sincere and
you're willing to trust him from now on
would you say amen and if you'll do that
he'll take you back now what about
rebaptism I I thought of a text let me
see if I can find it right quickly oh
yeah I got it let's go to Acts chapter
18 and verse 24 a certain Jew named
Apollos born at Alexandria an eloquent
man and mighty in the scriptures came to
Ephesus follow the picture
a man of God whose name was Apollos came
to a town called Ephesus
the next verse says this man was
instructed in the way of the Lord and
being fervent in the spirit he spake and
taught diligently the things of the Lord
knowing only the baptism of John
are you following me
Apollos came into town now make no
mistake about it he was a good man
diligent in teaching the things of the
Lord but his knowledge was not complete
he only knew about John's baptism
and he baptized people with that in mind
now let's go to Chapter 19 Verse 1. and
it came to pass that while Apollos was
at karrath in other words he was in
Ephesus and he traveled to Corinth
while Apollos was at Corinth Paul having
passed through the upper coasts came to
Ephesus and finding certain disciples
what did he find
disciples disciples are followers of
Christ
now I don't want you to miss this
Apollos taught at emphasis brought
people into the church but he did not
have complete knowledge
then he traveled over to Corinth
Paul succeeded him in Ephesus now that's
clear isn't it now let's read on
he found certain disciples and he said
unto them have ye received the Holy
Ghost since ye believed
and they said unto him we've not so much
has heard whether there be any Holy
Ghost so their knowledge was incomplete
what they learned was good
and they were disciples they were
children of God he loved them they loved
him but they did not know all that God
wanted them to know
then said Paul
under what then were you baptized and
they said unto unto John's baptism then
said Paul John verily baptized with the
baptism of repentance saying unto the
people that they should believe on him
which should come after him that is on
Christ
now there's the complete knowledge
verse 5 when they heard this they were
baptized in the name of the Lord Jesus
now I could paraphrase or add a word
without doing any damage to the
spirituality of the text I will do it
Apollos was it Ephesus lived and went to
Corinth Paul came to Ephesus and found
good people disciples with incomplete
knowledge
Paul said have you received the Holy
Ghost say we don't know about that
there's something vital that we didn't
know Paul said unto what then were you
baptized he said to John's baptism
that's all Apollos knew that's what he
taught us and then he said John baptized
with the baptism of repentance but he
was saying to the People You Must
Believe on Christ and receive the Holy
Ghost and the Bible says when they got
complete knowledge they were baptized
and I'm going to add a word they were
baptized again would you say Amen
the Bible says one Lord One Faith one
baptism that does not mean frequency it
means one method into one faith
now everybody who makes a mistake
doesn't need to be baptized send the
question in I'll answer that but there
are some who should if you're
backslidden severely if you have
reproached the Lord and turned your back
and his grace reaches you again you
ought to be baptized again next please
Pastor here's a person that wants to
know if you read your Bible every day
but you don't go to church is that
person a Christian you're not a
Christian by reading the Bible
the devil knows this Bible from Genesis
to Revelation you are a Christian when
you give your heart to Jesus accept his
forgiveness and his invitation to belong
to him and then you begin to obey him
then you will do what Jesus did a
Christian is one who does what Jesus did
Luke 4 16 says Jesus went to Nazareth
and as his custom was his habit was his
practice was he went into the church on
the Sabbath day would you say Amen
yesterday I read your text Hebrews 10 25
it says forsake not the assembling of
yourselves together as the matter of
some is some who stay home say I can be
a Christian watching TV
the Bible says don't do that assemble
together
and so much the more as you see the day
approaching let me tell you there is
power in aggregate worship and prayer
sometimes you can feel like giving up
and all you got to do is come into the
house of the Lord and sit at the feet of
Jesus and with fellow brothers and
sisters and your soul is lifted the Lord
has a church
and I can't understand for the life of
me why any converted person wouldn't
just love going to church next week
is a very touching question Dr Brooks if
I'm struggling with known sin and my
prayers are not being heard how will I
get the help I need to overcome how can
I come to the point of surrendering
completely to Jesus I want to but I just
can't seem to figure out how
well but love it we've gone over and
over it let me do it again one reason
it's not perceived is because we expect
it to be too complicated it is not
complicated it's not a fight it's a
surrender
it's not a great struggle it's giving up
if you know what I mean Say Amen
actually had two questions on here let
me speak to one first I'm struggling
with known sin and my prayers are not
being heard how will I get help I
suppose the idea I read a text the other
night says if I regard iniquity in my
heart the Lord will not hear me and I
suppose the person is saying if I'm
doing that and he won't hear me how can
I get help there are two kinds of
Sinners who pray one is penitent what is
that word
that's the man who wants to change
that's the man who's sorry for his sins
God will always hear that man as a
matter of fact as an old spiritual that
says King Jesus is the listening all
night long they hear some sin to pray
but on the other hand there's a sinner
who loves sin he enjoys it he doesn't
plan to quit but he wants his prayers
answered anyhow that's the bird that's
in trouble
so if you are penitent God is waiting to
hear you he loves you he will answer
your prayer and then how can I come to
the point of surrendering completely it
is an act of the will of what
you will never be strong enough but you
must will it and in faith you must come
to Jesus and will to be his and when you
will to be it and you repent of your
sins first John 1 9 says if if if we
confess our sins he is faithful and just
faithful meaning he's always there and
just meaning he won't treat this man one
way and you another he will treat you
alike
cover you with grace and the text says
if we confess our sins he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins and to
cleanse us of all unrighteousness the
night I preached on this I made the
point you cannot expect a phone call
from Heaven saying I just wanted you to
know I heard your prayer
and he's not going to send you a
telegram he's already given you his word
and the Bible says he cannot lie that
isn't all it says it's impossible for
him to lie when God tells you you can
count on it and when you believe it it
is not
when Jesus was here he healed people and
he always made a little speech and you
if you've read your Bible you know he
would either say thy faith hath made
thee whole or he would say according to
thy faith be it unto thee not according
to my faith but yours
and when you believe it is done if you
don't believe it's not that and that's
how you make a surrender to Christ and
you're not going to feel a great deal
differently all you will feel is in my
heart I want to be a Christian and you
start praying and you and you have to
grow
Jesus said you got a growing grace and
in knowledge and you'll get stronger and
stronger and stronger and don't give up
the minute you stumble I never saw a
baby yet that didn't stumble and if he
gave up you'd never learn how to walk
get up from there and Pray Again
how many times shall I forgive the
disciples said seventh time Jesus said
oh 70 times seven and that wasn't all
and we have to forgive as the father
forgive he loves to forgive
hang in there hold on keep trusting
and you'll watch yourself
rise above the things that have dragged
it out next week from one of our young
friends how old should you be to be
baptized I'm seven and I want to be
baptized but my parents say I'm too
young
well you you should talk to your parents
and your pastor and discuss this thing
some children are too young at seven
some are not
when God called little Samuel he was a
little rascal
and he became the prophet of the Lord
I had a Sunday school class when I was
six
and uh I started telling the kids they
should keep the Sabbath and they fired
me
but you can't measure it chronologically
that's what I'm saying what is your
perception
and if a child understands
I was telling my brethren today I was in
Palau art you were there with me we were
out in Palau in the Southwest Pacific
Ocean a little tiny Island out there and
there was a little girl who came to hear
five years old
she went home and told her parents I
want you to make me a baptismal garment
somebody in this family has got to obey
God
they they laughed it off and the next
week she came back dead serious she said
I told you I want a baptismal garment
somebody in this family has got to obey
God the parents now got the message they
came and gave their hearts to the Lord
too when I flew out of Palau there were
150 or 200 people out there to see us
off and I'm shaking hands and focal
hugging and kissing and when I got down
the line here stands this little girl
in that line she talked like she was 40
years old I've been over close to her
and I said darling I want to take a
picture of you and I've got it on the
slide that I can put on the screen God
deals with children too
you better be careful how you discourage
them at least counsel with the pastor
next please
from another young friend does Jesus
have any relatives yes the Bible says
that one day Jesus was quite busy
Matthews 12 and and someone came and
said your mother and your brethren
outside want to see you Jesus said who
is my mother and who is my brother
he had brothers and sisters and one of
his disciples was his brother yes he had
relatives next month Dr Brooks doesn't
the Bible say I must obey man's laws as
long as they don't interfere with God's
laws so when you're driving I'm going
with the majority of speed at 50 to 55
but the speed limit is 40 and there's an
accident and I am killed will Jesus come
and will I go to heaven
now I'm gonna leave that with Jesus
you see that some of these things are
relative
I remember one day I was in an emergency
and I took off with my lights blinking
and I was doing 100 miles an hour
somebody had run into my wife
and she was in the hospital thank God
she wasn't hurt badly
but I'd have felt sorry for any state
trooper trying to stop me
and we serve an understanding Lord but I
want to read you something because
people are constantly wondering about
this in the Book of Romans chapter 13
the Bible says let every soul be subject
unto the higher powers for there is no
power but of god the powers that be are
ordained of God whosoever therefore
resisteth the power resisteth the
ordinance of God and they that resist
shall receive to themselves damnation
Christians ought to be good citizens you
ought to obey the laws of Phoenix
Dr Brooks some Churches believe that
there are different levels of heaven and
only those perfect in the sight of God
will inherit the earth made new that
nobody will be destroyed by fire because
of the scripture that says will be the
least
Etc your response please no no no no not
mine the Bible the Bible the word of God
I am incredulous I cannot understand
how people can get some little
nebulous
idea
based on some misunderstood scripture
and come up with a Doctrine I don't
understand it Jesus said whoever shall
keep God's commandment Shall be Called
great in the kingdom of heaven and
whoever shall do whoever shall break one
of the least Shall be Called least in
Heaven and some folks think that means
you're going to be up there you'll just
be called leads what kind of Heaven
would that be you'd have classes of all
over again
doesn't mean that at all it means that
when they discuss your name in heaven
Angels report to encro and when they go
back and tell the Father the judge that
you were down here teaching people to
disobey they are discussing you and you
are the least thing that they discuss
but you still down here
now will people burn let me read it to
you Revelation 20 and verse 15. I want
to turn and read it so that you can know
I'm reading it and you write it down if
you would like to read it too Revelation
chapter 20 and verse 15 the Bible says
and whosoever was not found written in
the Book of Life was cast into the Lake
of Fire that's hell
now I want to read Revelation 21 verses
7 and 8. please listen Revelation 21 7
and 8. he that overcometh shall inherit
all things and I will be his God and he
shall be my son but the faithful
what does that mean fearful just mean
you're scared no it means you're afraid
to do what God says
or you're trying to serve him because
you're scared
but the fearful and unbelieving and the
Abominable and murderous and
whoremongers and Sorcerers and idolaters
and all liars shall have their part in
the lake which burneth with fire and
brimstone which is the second dead the
Bible says they're going to burn
and I believe what the Bible says don't
you Malachi chapter 4 they're going to
burn up not going to burn forever and
ever and ever and ever and ever and ever
that is another accusation against God
what kind of God would see a man's sin
for 60 years and burn him for 60 million
years doesn't make sense God is a just
God
the punishment will fit the crime
and the most severe crime is to know and
not do
you shall be beaten with many states
the Bible says that
but then it's going to burn out
and the Bible says in Malachi 4 the
wicked shall be ashes Under The Souls of
your feet they're going to burn on Earth
not down yonder but right here in
Phoenix they're going to burn and
they're going to burn out and they'll be
ashes Under The Souls of your feet what
does that mean it means when the Lord
opens the gates of the city and remakes
this Earth
with its blanket of green its flowering
shrubs it's singing birds its beautiful
flowers and it's fruits of many and
various kinds you will walk around on
the grass but underneath there will be
the fertilizer the Wicked the ashes next
place
our final question for tonight you know
out here Pastor Brooks we have some
scorpions and rattlesnakes now if
they're in your house does Thou shalt
not kill include them too
we get a version of this Everywhere I Go
Thou shalt not kill
Jesus said if you hate your brother he's
talking about human beings You're a
murderer
and I have a little saying I usually we
usually don't see anything like this
they talk about flies and mosquitoes but
here they got scorpions and rattlesnakes
and if they're in your house does Thou
shalt not kill include them my saying is
this Thou shalt kill thy Scorpion and
rattlesnake if thou killeth not thy
rattlesnake and Scorpion thy rattlesnake
and Scorpion might kill thee